Many people don't think promethium is very important,
including the makers of my tie. You can see here,
press the Damien neodymium and promethium is ran.
The back promethium is element 61,
between neodymium element 60 and samarium element 62.
Now people realize that there must be an element between those two
before promethium was discovered and the way that they
argued this,
the way that they thought that there must be an element was by looking at atomic
weights, relative atomic masses.
So this is a book from 1922,
which I bought as a secondhand book. When I was a school,
boy has a table of atomic numbers and the atomic weights.
And down here, you can see the table of the atomic weights.
Now it's called relative atomic mass between most of these
elements,
the difference in weight is somewhere between two
and three units. Occasionally it's a bit more,
but most of the time it's two or three.
And when you come to near Demian and Samir rim, the difference is six.
So the gap just seemed too big. So people thought they must be an element there.
They went through many claims.
We have found element 61, which turned out to be wrong.
And the reason why none of them found it with because element 61,
promethium is radioactive. It's longest lived.
Isotope has a lifetime of 3.7 years.
The most common one is even short-term.
It shouldn't that they produced.
There must be one between neodymium and samarium because of the gap
in the, in the waste,
in the masses couldn't they have done the same by looking at the valence of
neodymium and samarium, what those things reacted with and figured out, hang on,
this one must have 60 electrons and this one must have 62.
Therefore there must be one with 61.
I think that when people started doing this,
they didn't really know about electrons. As far as I knew,
Mendeleev didn't believe in electrons.
And the other thing is that these elements
not so much promethium,
but the other ones can have variable valence so they can make different
numbers of chlorides or oxide or oxides.
But it is true that one chemist did
use by looking at the reaction of hydrogen that near Demian
reacted with two atoms of hydrogen samarium reacted with
none so that he thought there should be an element that would react with one
atom of hydrogen. So you see bread do you're really clever.
It was only when the Manhattan project,
the nuclear weapons project started in the United States.
When there was a large amount of radioactive research being
done that enough radioactive isotopes were
formed that people had to chance of detecting it.
And in fact, the paper announcing the discovery of promethium,
not by its name,
but as element 61 was published just a few weeks,
probably four weeks before I was born.
So I feel a certain resonance with this element.
We were born a more or less the same time, still a very long time ago.
And
I've got the paper here.
And what's interesting about this paper is that it is extremely modest
compared to modern papers,
describing discovery of a new element where their press conferences,
big ceremonies.
You can see our video about some of these ceremonies here at the
end of a paragraph.
It just says in this paper is reported the successful
separation of these three elements.
The first have been achieved with radioisotopes of near Demian.
And these are the four words that describe the new discovery and
development. 61, you can't get much lower key than that.
The paper is by three authors.
Mariinsky Glen tenon and Keryell who were working
at the Clinton laboratories at Oak Ridge, Tennessee.
This is a laboratory that has been involved with the birth of many
elements.
Most recently they'd participated in the synthesis of
element, 117 Tennessee, which is named after Tennessee.
Now, the way that these three authors separated
promethium was by what was then a very new technique called
iron exchange chromatography in which they had the column of
essentially plastic beads that had acid groups on it.
And the element forms, positive irons,
which can interact with the acid to form a salt.
And if you have liquid flowing through the column,
in this case, it was a solution of the salt.
Then if you put in a mixture of metal ions at the top,
they are the different elements are attracted with different strengths to
the beads of this solid acid.
And they come out at different times at the bottom.
It turns out that the heaviest element comes out first and they have
grafts,
which show how these different elements come out here.
This is the key graph where they say the
number of liters going along here and the amount of radioactivity that
they measure. And there are different peaks.
And this is the peak for element 61.
Once they have isolated some solution with this element in it,
they can distinguish it say from near Demian because the radioactive decay has a
different half-life.
The energy of the electrons coming out is different and so on.
So they knew they had something different. I really liked reading this paper.
I read this one on the trime. When I was going home,
I got really excited by the time the time got to the final stuff,
this element has had a number of different names when people have thought
they've discovered it.
And hadn't because in the old days there wasn't a committee that looked at the
evidence before no limit was named.
So it was called or people thought they would call it Elysium.
Presumably after Illinois Florencia some of the Florence
in Italy site, Clooney, Liam, I don't know what about. And finally,
promethium promethium comes from the Greek legendary
figure. Prometheus's who stole fire from the gods.
The naming was a reference to the discovery of nuclear
weapons and in a way,
sort of stealing the power from the gods.
The promethium is formed as a product from the
nuclear efficient of other elements.
And I think it's important to realize that when say a uranium atom
splits, not all the uranium atoms split the same way.
So there are a number of different pathways and one of them fairly minor
pathway leads to promethium.
So once people started carrying out nuclear activities on the large
scale nuclear reactors,
then in the reaction products, the fishing products,
they accumulated significant quantities of promethium so
that you could start thinking about the uses. And there is one use,
which I think is fascinating of promethium,
which is fairly short lived.
It was a good technology,
but it didn't last very long was making batteries.
So-called nuclear batteries.
There are a number of applications where you want a battery to last,
as long as possible. For example, heart pacemakers.
When you have an electrical unit embedded inside somebody's
chest, thankfully I don't have one.
And you want the battery in that case to as long as possible conventional
batteries, even the ones in our phones really don't last very long.
As you probably know, you charge it up every day,
but the idea was to make so-called nuclear batteries.
And the idea of the promethium battery was that
promethium decays by B2 decay,
that is emitting an electron,
which in itself is promising for making a battery because the electrons
don't go very fast.
So it's easy to stop the electrons coming out of the battery.
So the idea is that you mix the promethium with a
material, which if the atoms are hit by an electron,
they give out light so-called phosphor.
Phosphors used to be used on old-fashioned television screens,
where you had the coating,
which was bombarded by electrons and light came out.
So you could see the picture.
So the idea is that you have a mixture of promethium and the phosphor,
which glows light comes out and you sandwich this between two
photo sales and the photo sales take the light and produce a
voltage.
And it has one enormous advantage over conventional
batteries. The conventional battery like this one,
or the ones you have in your cars are very temperature dependent.
If the weather's very cold,
it's difficult to start your car because the battery has lower voltage.
The premium battery was much less temperature
dependent.
So it could be cool to very low temperatures
and potentially say on the spacecraft and
would still produce a very similar voltage because it was not relying on the
chemical reaction, but on this photo electric effect,
the problem,
and the reason why the technology has now largely been superceded is that
the half-life of the promethium is very short.
So the amount of promethium in your battery decayed
by half every two point something years.
So if you were trying to travel to a distant star,
the battery would have gone flat long before you got there.
If you want one set of facts to impress your friends,
you can tell them that promethium hydroxide is Brown.
Promethium. Chloride is yellow and promethium. Nitrate is pink.